a show of support in a time of war
the u.s secretaries of state and defense
in the ukrainian capital to meet
president vladimir zelinsky
this was the first high-level visit by
u.s officials since russian forces
invaded
what you've done
in repelling the russians in the battle
of kiev is was extraordinary
and uh and inspiring quite frankly to
the rest of the world we've gotten used
to seeing you on video
around the world but it's great it's
good to see you in person
during a three-hour meeting the pair
promised to step up u.s military aid
including sending more advanced weapons
we will continue to do everything
possible to ensure that you're
successful
ukraine's president has accused allies
of being too slow to help saying they
shared responsibility for the war's
casualties but on sunday he said he was
grateful for u.s support and what he
called an important moment for his
country
the priority of this meeting is weaponry
support from the united states and our
partners in europe it's all about the
strength of our army and the second
issue is the sanctions against the
russian federation because of the
full-scale terror the russians are
waging in our country
while russia has failed to capture any
major city since the invasion started on
february 24th it has caused widespread
devastation
cities in the east and south are facing
daily bombardment what president
vladimir zelinski's called the battle
for donbass
the u.s says it wants to see russia
weakened so that it can never do
anything like this again
the bottom line
is this
we don't know how
the rest of this war will unfold
but we do know
that a sovereign independent ukraine
will be around a lot longer than
vladimir putin's on the scene
in terms of russia's war aims russia has
already failed and ukraine has already
succeeded
speaking in poland after their meeting
the secretaries outlined what will be
included in the latest 700 million
dollar package to ukraine and
neighbouring countries
so they need long-range fires
you've heard them express a need for
tanks we believe that they we can win
they can win if they have the right
equipment the right support the visit
comes just days before the u.n secretary
general antonio gutierrez is due to
travel to moscow then keefe for meetings
with leaders from both sides secretary
blinken says guterres will be carrying a
strong and clear message to the russian
president but he needs to end this war
now
alexia bryan al-jazeera
live to my kana in washington dc mike a
strong message of solidarity from the
biden administration there and the u.s
resuming its diplomatic presence in
ukraine
yes uh very strong developments in terms
of u.s support for ukraine its most
senior cabinet officials being sent
there and the secretary of state and the
secretary of defense meeting there with
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
certainly this is a strong signal from
the united states and one must note too
that it has now announced a new
ambassador to ukraine
bridget brink is the current ambassador
to slovakia
she is a professional diplomat this is
very important and also she is extremely
experienced within the region and she
would be well known by the us's european
allies which would be of great comfort
to them having a diplomat in place who
they are well aware of and who they know
and who is not a political appointment
who is a career state department officer
so all of these factors together very
important in terms of the us
presence in ukraine saying as well that
it's sending diplomats back in the
coming week those diplomats having been
brought out at the beginning of the war
and also significantly the us is going
to resume training of ukrainian military
on what it says are undisclosed weapon
systems so all of these factors together
show an uptick in the biden
administration's involvement in that war
in ukraine
mike hanna in washington dc thank you
very much for that let's go now live to
charlie stratford
who joins us from the front line in
eastern ukraine you're near the city of
slovyansk which is close to the front
line i understand tell us about what's
been happening
yeah we're not actually on the front
line here but then front lines seem to
be moving so
rapidly some days in this area of
eastern ukraine we're actually north of
slovansk which is one of the biggest
cities that is still under full
ukrainian government military control
adjacent to the city of krematorsk as
well a very large urban area the road
behind me leads up to a town called
isiam
which
the russian military have controlled for
a number of weeks they are trying to
push down this road to basically
surround slavyans which is to say is in
that direction earlier today
this morning we were close to a town
called liman which is to my left which
is to the east of here um and we know
there's a lot of heavy fighting going on
in that town we were speaking to
civilians that were being evacuated out
of it volunteers ukrainian volunteers
going in and picking them up them
describing
terrifying scenes as as we've been
reporting for weeks now as these
civilians try and evacuate areas
as seemingly the russians make a push
towards slavyansk we also saw ambulances
coming out uh we saw one wounded
ukrainian soldiers obviously the
ukrainian military very sensitive about
showing that sort of information despite
obviously admitting that it is a war but
obviously concerned about the identities
of injured uh military personnel
we also understand that there is a push
to the west of here also towards
slavians we understand that the russian
military are hitting targets there in
the last few minutes from where i'm
standing we've seen missiles being
launched
towards what can only be described or we
understand would be targets in the east
russian positions
from in front of me and just just to the
left here as well
we had a lot of incoming and outgoing
shelling early in the morning the thing
situation has calmed down
in the last couple of hours in this area
but as i say the ukrainian military are
claiming that
russian forces trying to push towards
serbians have so far failed in that
endeavor
but this is one could only really
describe it potentially as being the
quiet before the storm the streets of
slavyansk are pretty much empty
we i can still hear a siren being an
alarm
in the distance
most of the civilians of slovenians have
have left
and the reason why this area is so
important as i say is because it is one
of the largest urban areas still under
ukrainian control
russian forces pushing in from from the
northeast
the north and the northwest as well as
certain areas of the east
the ukrainian military is saying that
there is ongoing fighting in various
villages to the east of here also with
respect to what's going on in mariopol
of course that city that has seen such
heavy fighting as according to some
reports and we've seen the pictures as
as the world has a city that has pretty
much been flattened um the ukrainian
deputy prime minister saying there is as
yet still no agreement the russians are
still she's saying the russians still
refusing to agree on setting up some
sort of humanitarian corridor to get out
what we understand are around a thousand
civilians trapped
under that steel works that giant great
soviet-built industrial plant where um
still there are ukrainian fighters
ukrainian military in there we
understand that uh obviously the
civilians haven't left um and there is
still fighting to try as the russians
try and clear that area of those
ukrainian fighters and ukrainian
military so of course great concern
they're still for those civilians
trapped um in mariopol but as i say
there are still a lot of civilians
trapped in towns around this area as it
seems the russians russian military
forces try and push
towards slavyansk all right charlie
thank you very much for that update
charles stratford in slovak there now to
moscow where russian president vladimir
putin has been speaking in the last few
hours he was addressing a meeting of the
general prosecutor's office let's bring
in dorset jabari in moscow forest the
president we heard
a very defiant message from vladimir
putin
yes certainly
the russian president was
discussing the
upcoming year and the agenda and the
main issues that his country's general
prosecutor's office will have to focus
on according to vladimir putin the
members of this office have to remain
vigilant and united because he believes
that there is a full scale campaign
being waged against
his country's
media as well as the
military
the president's saying that
there is a lot of misinformation and
provocations against the russia's the
russian military so it is the job of the
general prosecutor's office to
prevent the spread of fake information
uh online and from for media vladimir
putin seemingly very directly
targeting the foreign media saying that
they are extremists that are being their
views being presented in the foreign
media and he advised his
general prosecutor's office to remain
vigilant he also shared some information
about a
operation that the
fsb uh managed to prevent from taking
place according to the president the
federal security services thwarted an
attempt on the life of a very prominent
state tv presenter vladimir sullivan who
is one of the most well-known figures in
this country he has a daily
program here in the evenings on state tv
and he is known to be very much a strong
supporter of vladimir putin and
according to the president there was a
number of arrests made by the security
services who were part of a neo-nazi
group as they called them and they have
been detained with the intention of
trying to
kill this
state tv presenter this was another
example by
vladimir putin of how
his country has been under attack from
the west and specifically the united
states he says he believes that the cia
had a hand in this as well he also
talked about the other
various forms of
the
sabotage attempts by western countries
on russian society let's listen to some
of what he had to say
the other task is coming forward to
break russia from within but they can't
do it because our society is showing its
unity and support our armed forces and
our efforts to maintain the security of
russia and the citizens of donbass
all right dorsa we heard from charlie
just a moment ago about the situation in
mario paul and those humanitarian
portals the ukrainians saying that
there's still
no humanitarian corridors open in
mariopol what is russia saying about
this
well the russian defense ministry has
been announcing these so-called
ceasefires short-term
as they are in mariopol to allow the
civilians to um evacuate that steel
plant and also allow give an opportunity
to those
ukrainian fighters that are holed up in
there to surrender this is something
that has been ongoing for the past 10
days or so but every opportunity that is
announced by the russians
seemingly does not work out the
ukrainian side accusing russia that
they're not actually
establishing any kind of ceasefire that
the attacks continue during that time
also there have been accusations that
the
civilians allowed to leave any areas
during these ceasefires are forced to go
into areas in russia and that is
something of course that the civilians
would not agree to in general but the
russian defense ministry saying that
they have on a regular basis provided
these ceasefires and it is the ukrainian
side that is not uh withholding uh
upholding rather their end of the deal
they don't want to actually evacuate the
civilians they're being used by the
ukrainian fighters that are still in
there in an attempt to prevent the
russians from storming this facility of
course the russian president had ordered
on thursday that no russian troops enter
this facility and just to seal it up and
not allow anybody to go in or out in an
attempt to basically force
whatever
fighters are left in there to surrender
at any point there is a
strong sense that this is now yet
another attempt by the russian defense
ministry to show the international
community that they are trying to
establish humanitarian corridors of
course we have the secretary general of
the united nations coming to moscow on
tuesday and certainly this will be an
example of how the russians will show
that they are trying to establish some
kind of a
ceasefire to allow those
civilians to leave but we'll have to
wait and see what the secretary general
will have to say indeed we will follow
that visit with you of course social
barrie live for us there in moscow
and the international criminal chief
prosecutor has announced that it will
participate in a joint eu investigation
team that is looking into allegations of
international crimes in ukraine